on episode 2 of cooking potatoes a
hundred different ways we're making 15
hour potatoes you want to start with
using a mandolin you get ultra thin
slices of potato that you'll then
transfer to a bowl and add melted butter
and garlic powder next you'll transfer
this buttery goodness to a baking dish
then bake low and slow for three hours
until potatoes are tender you'll place a
piece of parchment paper on top followed
by another baking dish with weights and
refrigerate for at least 12 hours flip
the cold potatoes onto a cutting board
and slice it to perfect little cubes
while these do take more time than
effort in my opinion I'd say it's well
worth giving it a solid 10 out of 10.